all right here's the big story this is
from Fox News they say at least 40
babies some beheaded found by is uh
Israel soldiers in Hamas attacked
Village IDF Major General itai verv
described the scene in kafar Aza as a
massacre Israel's militar discovered
unspeakable Horrors in an Israeli
community that was attacked by Hamas on
Saturday including dozens of dead babies
some with their heads chopped off
Israeli media reported according to
local Israeli Outlet I24 news IDF
soldiers moved into Aza one of the
community's Hamas terrorists invaded
early Saturday morning and discovered
about 40 dead babies some decapitated
now they say it several times before the
article gets started the IDF were
removing the bodies of victims found in
the area when they found the children's
remains Israeli soldiers are attempting
to use bones to identify the victims
according to the report it's not a war
it's not a battlefield you see the
babies the mother the father in their
bedrooms in their protection rooms and
how the terrorists killed them IDF Major
General eai veru said describing the
scene I24 reported it's a massacre now
immediately A lot of people brought up
uh the Nira testimony which is a young
woman Nira alabah in the early 90s in
1990 early 90s who had stated that
saddam's forces were pulling babies out
of incubators and leaving them to die so
the news is obviously shocking and the
first thing I'm just going to say as we
get into this subject matter is look man
this is such a heated issue there are
there's people uh tweeting out photos
and videos they're saying uh uh the the
attacks that's pure evil don't support
this you've got tweets from people like
Ben chapiro saying there's a big
difference between Israel trying to
prevent civilian deaths and Hamas
targeting civilians so obviously this is
extremely heated that being said I
remain skeptical on stories like this
there are a lot of videos I'm seeing
shared I can't prove these videos are
what people say they are there are some
videos that are easily discernable like
yes there's there's paratroopers coming
in some of these are clearly not not
from uh they're not what people will do
is I'll take videos from other conflicts
and then they'll capture them and put
them as if it was now to shock you or
whatever some of the videos we've seen
are are are clear and plain as day uh
and I think the reporting speak for
itself but then there are more shocking
stories like this there are videos that
start right in the middle of something
egregious happening that we don't know
where they come from so I just hope
everybody keeps a level head to the best
of their abilities we can try and figure
out what's true and what isn't but I'm
curious what all of you guys think about
this latest reporting because this is
look the the idea that babies are are
beheaded is is international casses
belly I mean it is the US sending a
strike group a carrier group this is we
rally our allies and say these terrorist
groups Must Be Stopped that's why I have
fears about what what these stories uh
mean I the first thing I you know heard
or the first thing that I thought when I
heard it was obviously the uh the
stories that led to the first Iraq war
um the that's the N testimony yeah so I
mean that was the first thing I thought
of and I mean there's plenty of actual
evidence of horrible things happening
when the the Palestinians actually you
know launched the attack I think it was
like 1500 actual Fighters they said
actually went into Palestine there's
into Israel you mean yeah I'm sorry into
into Israel um there's plenty of
evidence that they killed innocent
people there's plenty of evidence that
they you know carried out what amounts
to a terror attack it's not a military
operation there's plenty of evidence so
there are videos you don't want watch
absolutely and and I don't so I don't
need to I don't need to believe that
they were cutting off baby's heads to
condemn the attack on Israel so you know
I if if it turns out that it happened
I'm not shocked I mean I was alive when
Isis when when the the the uh the
Islamic State was in existence and the
and I saw videos of them cutting off
people's heads and doing terrible things
I remember 9/11 you know that you don't
need to have this particular thing to be
real to be like okay terrorists do
really horrible horrible things with the
intent of terrorizing people I'm curious
what you think Max yeah I I would be
shocked first of all because Hamas is
mortally opposed to Isis and salafi
elements they've actually battled them
in the streets in Rafa before uh they
consider them a threat to their
stability and is Israeli intelligence
actually has worked with salafi elements
in Gaza to destabilize Hamas just as
Israeli intelligence supported Hamas to
destabilize the PLO when it controlled
Gaza in the 1980s so I would be shocked
if they employed something like this the
only source so far on this story is one
Israeli soldier uh who's a very
interesting character we've traced as
identity at the gry zone and it comes
through a state sponsored Israeli media
organization as you pointed out I24 the
reporter Nicole sedc who just went to
kafar oza and said I'm hearing that
babies were beheaded then the Israeli
foreign Ministry goes and blasts it out
40 babies beheaded why because the US
bombed the crap out of Isis in raqqa
that we destroyed half of the city of
raqa and that's what Israel wants us to
do to Iran they want us to see Hamas as
Isis and then to get involved in their
regional conflict so they're pushing
this story The Source is a Israeli
soldier named davidi benzion who is a
settler leader he's from one of the
fanatical wings of Israeli politics and
he uh you know he's a reservist he's
serving in the military but he got in
trouble earlier this year because he
called for an entire Palestinian Village
to be wiped off the map next to his
illegal settlement in the West Bank and
he's the guy go that she's interviewing
as her credible witness I don't trust it
and as you said Israel has enough to go
on right now to try to portray itself
even though it's the occupier and
besieger of the Gaza Strip according to
international law to portray itself as a
victim why do they need to do this it's
because it's because they're trying to
draw the US in I agree with that for
sure that because because that's why
everybody immediately brings up the near
testimony what will shock Americans to
the most extreme degree to justify us
involvement you should break that down
though like the near testimony yeah I
mean I I can I can break it down we have
the Wikipedia pulled up uh false
testimony given to the United States
Congress Congressional human rights
caucus October 10th 1990 by a
15-year-old girl who was publicly
identified by the time by her first name
Nira the testimony was widely publicized
and was cited numerous times by US
senators and George HW Bush in their
rationale to to support Kuwait in the
Gulf War in 1992 it was revealed n uh
nira's last name was Al saah and that
she was the daughter of Saud Al saah the
Kuwaiti ambassador to the US furthermore
it was revealed that a testimony was
organized as part of the citizens for a
free Kuwait public relations Campaign
which was run by the American public
relations firm Hill and Nolton for the
Kuwaiti government following this alah's
testimony has become regarded as a
classic example of modern atrocity
propaganda so uh it is it it is false
testimony uh her story initially was
even corroborated by Amnesty
International so this is crazy I mean
I'm a little kid I'm four years old when
this stuff's going down actually what
what month was it it was October so I
was yeah I was the story was that they
were stabbing babies in incubators with
bayonets and throwing them on the ground
so that way they could take the
incubators back to Iraq from Kuwait that
was the that was the story like and I
mean I was 15 when I heard it or
whatever so you know what the hell did I
know but I was like oh that's so
terrible but now looking back obviously
it's like it especially today with the
the way that we have the ability to
communicate and produce fake videos and
have videos that don't have any context
with them you have to be really careful
you know look man uh do I think it's
possible that some babies were killed
yes absolutely uh if if if they're if
they're coming into autz and they're
shooting yeah there's Crossfire I see
kids killed in Chicago right it's and
then you're in an active conflict Zone
likely going to happen I think it's
possible that uh uh like the most
reasonable and rational thing that could
that that I would say highest
probability in terms of this being
truthful is that you know a couple
babies died one had its man this is such
horrible thing to say but SE severely
injured to the point of decapitation and
then someone passes it along and it
purple monkey dishwashers itself the
telephones itself into 40 babies killed
beheaded and a more extreme version of
the story but now it serves political
purpose so it escalates to a point where
Fox News is reporting it headline as
though it's you know proven the
challenging thing is what do you need
how do you prove it what do you like
what do you do if this is if this is
true if they're not lying well there's
another purpose to it which is to
deflect from the obviously true real
videos of babies being killed by Israeli
air strikes all across the Gaza Strip
when I was in Gaza in 2014 I went to Han
Yunis which is in the southeast
uh had been completely destroyed at its
eastern Edge by the Israeli military and
the casualties were so intense that the
hospital started filling up in Khan
yunas and I went to a small hospital and
talked to the head of the hospital and
he showed me photos and I've these
photos are on my Twitter page from the
time all real he had to bring in from
local shops ice cream coolers to store
dead babies in because the mortuaries
had run out of space and now we see
Israel attacking the hospital in banoon
in the north is completely out of
commission uh all of these hospitals are
coming under attack so babies are dying
in the Gaza Strip there's video right
now Jackson hle just tweeted a video of
a father carrying his baby out of the
rubble there's another video on times of
Gaza a local publication of a father
putting his infant daughter to sleep for
the last time and they've completely
erased these casualties they've always
been erased and that's part of what
fuels the the violence and the
ruthlessness that we see from these
Fighters is that they want to avenge
what they call their Martyrs and that
fuels what is you know referred to as
the cycle of violence this the
invisibilization of them so you you you
think that some Hamas Fighters they they
target civilians because civilians and
Gaza are targeted well first of all let
let's let's let's let's point out
another thing that's being left out of
the conversation what CNN never showed
this fox never showed this they targeted
military bases primarily military bases
like nahal that are maintaining the
siege of Gaza and they overwhelmed those
bases and humiliated the fourth most
powerful military on the planet with a
Bluewater Navy with nuclear weapons some
of these Fighters were filmed entering
the bases with no shoes on they're using
homemade weapons
AK-47s uh paragliders fishing boats to
get in this is not a powerful Army and
they humiliated them thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8:00 p.m. and become a member
over at timcast.net